So once we learn our WHY
we have the opportunity to apply it in
all different parts of our lives.
So for jobs for example
we want to work for a company that
our WHY complements
the company's WHY.
We're more likely to "fit."
We've more likely to feel like we "belong."
It goes with our friends too
believe it or not.
We do it inherently
there's lots of nice people in the world
but we're not friends with everybody in the world.
We're friends with the people that
we share values with
but sometimes we have people in our lives
that we may have a good time with them
but it's not a deep meaningful relationship.
Knowing your WHY actually helps you
understand why the deep meaningful relationships
are the deep meaningful relationships.
It's a new way of understanding the value
of people in our lives.
You know how trust builds.
The opportunity is to use it
to find things that are more likely
to produce
joy, success, focus, inspiration
and fulfillment
in the decisions we make,
the books we read,
the people we keep in our lives,
where we invest our time
and where we invest our energy.
We get a limited amount of time
in the day and
a limited amount of years on the planet.
It's the great equalizer
whether we're rich or poor
we all have 24 hours in a day.
And the idea is to
get as much out of those hours
and as much out of those years
as possible.